اعلانات رابطه العالم الاسلامي عن توقيعها
اتفاقيه شراكه واطلاق المعمل الدولي
للاديان مع جامعه كولومبيا في امريكا يهدف
المعمل العالمي الى بناء القدرات المضاده
لمفاهيم الكراهيه والعنف والصدام الحضاري
وحمايه المجتمعات من اشكال الكراهيه كافه
من نيويورك تنضم الينا مدير التنفيذي
للمعمل الدولي للاديان البروفيسوره امرا
سبيك مرحبا بك معنا في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض دعينا نعرف اولا ما هي فكره هذا
المعمل المعمل الدولي طبيعه الشراكه ايضا
التي وقعت بين رابطه العالم الاسلامي
وكذلك بين جامعه كولومبيا
ماتش الاستضافه
وبين الرابطه العالم الاسلامي وجامعه
كولومبيا وقد تشرفت في ليله القاضي
سعاده الدكتور محمد العيسى قبل نحو سنه
وقد اجرين النقاش المستفيدين بشان التحدي
المتمثل في زياده الكراهيه والعنف في
العالم
الذي قمت به على مدى سنوات
طويل انا مسلمه من البوسنه وقد عشته
وقلتله اربع سنوات في الحصار في البوسنه
في التسعينات عندما كنت في مقتبل العمر
وقد وجاته
العنفدت واغلبيه افراد اسرتي وقد فجر منزل
ايضا
ومن الكراهيه وقضى عليه كانت مهمه في
الحياه
هذه المهمه مع سعاده الدكتور محمد العيسى
الامين العام لربطه العالم الاسلامي وبناء
على النقاش الاولي الذي اجريناها عقدنا
عده اجتماعات ادت الى صياغه هذا
المعمل الاول من نوع في العالم الذي يركز
اساسا على مكافحه الكراهيه والعنف في
الولايات المتحده
واعتقد انها سيكون لها اثار دوليه كبيره
مبادره وسطيها بالهائله سيكون لها اثار
ايضا حتى كبيره على ال ال المجتمعات ايضا
ما هي هذه الاثاره المتوقعه ولماذا هذا
المعمل بروفيسوره يعني
اختصا بفكره محاربه الكراهيه وايضا ربما
العنف الصدام الحضاري لماذا ركز على هذه
النقاط تحديدا
في العالم
وهنا في الولايات المتحده في سنتين
الماضيتين عملته بشكل وثيق مع الحكومه
الاتحاديه الامريكيه وزاره الداخليه التي
لها مركز
للشركات وفي السابق تم اطلاق العديد من
المشاري الاساسيه
في الولايات المتحده ومن خلال ارتفاع كبير
في الخطابات الكراهيه والعنف في المدارس
فان خطابات التي تلقى في المدارس يصبح
اشعه عاديه بالنسبه لهؤلاء الاطفال عندما
يكبرون هذا يؤدي الى الكراهيه والحروب
والانقسامات وبالتالي نحن نسعى لتدخل على
مستوى كافه الفئات العمريه وكذلك مع
البالغين والقاده يقومون بدور اساسي لان
خطابات مهمه للغايه ونركز بلاساس على
الفضاء من خلال العمل مع الاطفال
عماد عماد
برامج تؤدي الى تغيير ذهنياتهم وتساعدهم
على الايمان بالقيم الانسانيه المشتركه
المتمثله في الاحترام المتبادل بدلا من
نشر الكراهيه
وبغد النظر عن العرق او اللون او الثقافه
او الدين اذن نحن نسعى لكسر هذه الحواجز
من خلال تدخل ومنعي الكراهيه في صفوف
المدرسيه وهنا ياتي سؤال مهم بروفيسوره
لاي مدى هذا ما القادر فعلا على الاسلام
في همم في خفض او حتى هذا
النمو الخطاب الكراهيه خطاب العمر ايضا
همم حتى همم كذلك الذي ذكرته قبل قليل
المستعد
جماعيه وخسرت كل شيء بسبب الكراهيه وعندما
تبقى على قيد الحياه من اشد انواع العنف
وتعرضت لذلك لان اني كنت طفله مسلمه في
ذلك الوقت
العالم الاسلامي وهي الاكبر والاهم
والدينا شارك ايضا مع جامعه كولومبيا وهي
من الاكبر الجامعات المؤثره في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه العالم في
شوف المدرسيه استاذه لدي طلاب جاءوا من
جميع ارجاء العالم وقد تغيروا بفضل العمل
الذي نقوم به ويمكن لنا ان نحدث فرق وبناء
على البرنامج الذي ننفذه سنحدث الفارق قبل
بدعته سنوات اطلقنا مشروعا شارك فيه طلاب
بيركز بالاساس على
الشعور المناهض للمسلمين في الولايات
المتحده جمعنا البيانات اولا ورايت ان
رحلتي في مجال التعليم في الولايات
المتحده اظهرت لتجارب
بشانني المواقف المناهده للمسلمين في
الولايات المتحده ومن خلال هذه البيانات
التي جمعناها راينا انه يمكن ان نركز على
الاطفال وكنا بانشاء منهاج لتدريب
المعلمين في الولايات المتحده تعالج
بطريقه مبتكره للغايه هذا الشعور
واستطعنا ان نرى فريقا كبير في ذهني اذا
لدينا
مكونات اساسيان سوف يؤديان الى تحقيق
النجاح من خلال الدعم المؤسسات
والمنظمات العالم
الاسلامي ثم لدينا ادوات البحث وخبره
لا انا شخصيا ولكن كل من يعمل معي في هذا
الاشراك الجميع ملتزم لمحاربه الكراهيه
سنبذل قصار جهدنا ونحن نؤمن باننا يمكن ان
نحدث الفارق والله شكرا جزيلا لك على
المشاركه معي في نشاره الربيعه من نيويورك
انضمت الينا المدير التنفيذي للمعمل
الدولي للاديان البروفيسيوره الامراض